[Music]
foreign
we're going to Kodiak Island Alaska it's
gonna be quite the adventure
you gotta love this Spring weather
[Music]
Kodiak Island is an incredible spot you
have to fly or take about a 12-hour
ferry to get here so very remote it's
the second largest island in the U.S
it's also home for the largest of the
grizzly bears and like a lot of coastal
Alaska most the time it's wet and rainy
so do you want to go island hopping so
here you go
oh look here it is
we're at the Kodiak Baptist Mission here
where they have their Heritage Ranch
at the ranch there's a lot of goats
we also have pigs some horses and they
have about 22 cattle just offshore on an
island that we're going to be looking at
while we're here hi guys hello how are
you good you must be Dr Dan great that
you make it yes good to meet you so
today I'm working with Dr Dan 2017. it's
my first year here so I guess four years
out he lives and works in Wisconsin but
he comes to Kodiak twice a year to help
with a lot of farm work and Kelly
Foreman runs the show here in Sierra
admire along as well and we're all gonna
be flat out busy this week hey we're
right over here okay they're all
relaxing you know after the morning
milking how cute is that oh my gosh look
at the wide load there she's super
pregnant probably gonna have a couple of
births while you're here so we are in
baby goat season and that is really
challenging we have about 40-ish goats
it just depends on what day it is and
how many kids we've had that day and how
much sleep we've had to be able to count
how many goats that we do have it gets a
little bit crazy one of the goats has
been lame yes fidget she's over here
actually on her knees oh yeah you can
see her she's our earless goat she
actually lost her ears to frostbite whoa
dude
so fidget is one of my middle-aged
milking does and just in the last couple
of months she started to go down on her
knees not being able to walk normally
the quality of life that our animals
have it's really important to me and I
don't want to see fidget and pain sorry
Princess so as I'm watching fidget I see
that she's
looking pretty good except for the fact
that she's on her knees you're mad about
it I mean that looks awful but she looks
bright she's alert she's cruising around
eating oh fidget
when we encourage her to stand up she
can she walks a few steps but then she
gets right back down so that tells me
there's something painful in her feet or
the action of walking that's making it
difficult for her
yeah I'd say everywhere no all four yeah
all four features which is every every
step is yeah it's hurting
Kelly had contacted me about a month ago
she's pretty concerned about fidget all
right
she doesn't remember her being injured
it came on fairly suddenly you know in
goats with some infectious diseases a
viral disease that can cause some
lameness and sometimes past injuries
could cause that so I'm very concerned
with what we might find here
so
[Music]
so as I'm looking at her feet I'm
looking for reasons why they're going to
be sore now I would expect in a really
wet environment they be they can be
getting a lot of foot rot looking good
absolutely nothing in there like Perfect
Skin but yeah I'm not seeing any sign of
foot rot or anything like that I see
very healthy looking Hooves absolutely
no swelling in any of her joints oh that
hurts I'm sorry she's quenching I mean
she does not like you yeah like that
feeling at all really the only thing I'm
finding is as I'm touching her her toes
in between her toes she's flinching it's
very tender there so why don't we start
getting some x-rays in
I do not have access to a portable x-ray
machines so having Dr Oakley it's just
wonderful all right let's get your
and
then good okay that one looks good
Kodiak Island is remote we do not have
the large animal vet here to have Dr
Oakley and Dr Dan here together
it's amazing better get the udder out of
the way here I'm the otter holder
designated otter holder the Glamorous
side of veterinary medicine
yeah
that one looks good I don't actually
have a folding table but I do have a
goat table
she's itchy my table is very well
behaved she's happy to have some
attention and I'm happy to have a table
so it's a win-win
don't do it don't do it
goats are a lot of fun but they're
definitely a little bit of a nuisance
sometimes let's start chewing your hair
chewing your equipment uh-oh you have to
have eyes everywhere when you're working
with goats oh
that's weird
I feel like the density is way less in
these two bones and
I definitely see arthritis there and
around that edge there I'm definitely
seeing a little bit of fuzziness a
little bit of arthritis we're also
seeing some inflammation down around the
bone called the navicular bone and that
can be seen when you have a little bit
of laminitis that's an inflammation in
their hooves that makes it really
painful to walk on them the biggest part
is you just don't want them to be in
pain it wouldn't be a bad idea then to
be treating her with an
anti-inflammatory it might take a few
days of it but then she should be up
walking
I'm thrilled to know that we may be able
to do something to keep her here okay we
can get her started on some treatment
you better feeling better that's good we
have like the Dream Team and the Goat
pen it's really worked out perfect
[Music]
are y'all ready to catch a horse
my name's Johnny Walker I'm actually the
director of the Baptist Mission as hard
as that might be to believe
we're getting ready to catch that bay
right there the one with the black Mane
that horse is called marlin but his
nickname's alligator Bill cause he's bit
so many people
he might be a little hard to catch there
we got once they get wind out
we're gonna catch him and then take him
put him on the boat take him across that
water there to that Island
Johnny first came to Kodiak from West
Virginia so that kids could ride ponies
we have a giant summer camp here
about 150 kids come
and one of the most popular programs we
have is our riding program
he has a way with forces he has so much
patience good morning gentlemen he's
actually legitimately like a Horseless
fur he's that guy
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
good boy
so today we need to transport Marlin
over to Woody Island to spend the summer
come on come on let's
go come on we have the cattle over there
so he'll be able to help round up the
cattle but you can also pull him in for
pony rides for the summer campers that
come over hey Mr Walker we ready we're
all set so the goal is to get him under
the boat across the channel and out onto
the beach without any difficulty
[Music]
yeah that's cool we're going to be doing
the Alaska version of island hopping
he's actually going to go on the front
of What's called the landing craft which
is a boat that can actually pull right
up on a beach but horses can be pretty
skittish they are prey animals their
go-to is to run and get out of the way
or the kick so you know if they're not
used to certain sounds or flashes of
movement they can definitely explode
this is about as hard a thing as you're
ever going to do with the horse just
load him in that little bobbin stall
down there okay no sedation needed
well we'll see hopefully not one of the
reasons I'm here is if things get really
Rowdy and we see that he's just not
going to have it I will go ahead and
give him a quick sedation
also if Marlin ends up with any injuries
lacerations just in case I'm ready might
be a little intense
I always get nervous when we transport a
horse if that horse jumps out of the
boat you aren't going to save it are you
good Johnny
it's a little boat and a big horse you
know we don't want him to try to jump
over the side I mean obviously didn't
tip the boat over you know the horse has
the ability to sink the boat if he wants
to next hour or two pretty
nerve-wracking the second that that
horse gets on pull that gate shut quick
it's okay
putting a horse in a little box and
getting him out in the water is not a
natural act all of them are skittish
when they get on the boat
hey hey
he is antsy he does not appreciate this
so Dr Oakley is helping um feeding him
this reminds me like we're really
nervous that's something you're like
just give me chocolate just give me
chocolate yeah there was he just gave
the little alligator yeah Marlin's
nervous just doing a lot of like excited
nervous things and also doing a little
bit of nervous eating it's like like Tom
Tom you know he's just grabbing the food
alligator Beal he feels to me like he's
ready to explode
[Music]
foreign
here we go
this isn't the essence we need to get
into the island
no
it gets nervous that little bite comes
right in there he really we're almost
there and Marlon reaches over and nips
Kelly I mean he's like let me off this
boat he's trying to turn around look
behind him I think almost to look for a
way to get off on his own so it's time
to get him over there before he ratchets
this up anymore easy almost there almost
here buddy
everybody to the back a little bit
[Music]
as we're getting closer to see all the
islands in the distance most of them
with black sand beaches and cliffs I
know later I'm going to enjoy it but
right now I really just want to get this
horse off the boat and then I can look
around and appreciate it
oh my gosh they're running that's so
funny they're hollering back at us here
[Laughter]
[Music]
they gave a couple hollers to the cows
and all the cows and the horses came too
he totally just saw everybody
oh who is that did you see your friend
suddenly Marlin sees the horses and when
he sees them it's like that's all he's
just locked in that's all he wants to
look at they start calling to each other
which is very common in horses see each
other from a distance there's a few
winnies to greet each other
it's like he's got his own fan club his
own like welcoming committee who are
like yes you made it buddy
hurry hurry hurry hurry I got him got
him all right okay can you turn friend
you did it buddy
all right he'll jump Michelle yep come
on buddy you got it you can do it come
on sir
are you ready to be free
oh yeah you're ready
all right there you go
[Music]
nice look how happy they are
he's like vacation
it went good he's free here he can go
anywhere he wants everybody's happy
oh my gosh those cattle are so cute
this is Woody Island we have 600 acres
here we have 22 cows now we have one
Bull and on an island where we depend on
boats to bring food and this and that
this is our emergency food pantry you're
looking at behind me here
it's one of the few places left where
you have thousands and thousands of
Acres of free range so a lot of the beef
cattle and other animals are free-range
here
and also if you aren't going to have
that Kodiak brown bear on the island so
it's a relatively safe place to have
livestock oh my God the cow is trying to
get on the boat buttercup
basically all of these cattle are feral
except for Miss Buttercup hello
buttercup hello she was a bottle raised
baby that they had back at Heritage
Ranch they raised her up and brought her
out here she's still willing to come
right up to us and you know basically
get up in all of our business oh hey
there Buttercup butterscotch butter ball
[Music]
and here he come
here comes the bull the man that we've
come to see he's just finally making his
way catching up with the rest of the
cows
the goal is
to have that one bull breed the rest of
the cattle to be able to have
sustainable agriculture you need babies
and so we need to have some pregnant
cattle
watch out back we're right side and
occasionally you see him take a little
misstep with it which maybe explains why
he's moving slow
he's two years old he got hurt sometimes
when he was one year old started limping
and it was very very noticeable to the
point that we came over here to put him
down and he seemed a little better
and we decided to let him try it and to
date he has not had any
tags she has to be able to move with a
herd he has to be able to get up and
mount the cows and if he's got a bad leg
that can be very difficult in some Bowls
because of injuries they can no longer
breathe
if he does have a bum leg and he's not
able to breed
yeah that we don't want to keep him here
so that's what we'd like to get checked
as I'm watching a move I can definitely
see a lameness the most obvious sign is
he's actually dragging the toe he's not
really lifting that leg up
I'm going to get out the dart gun
now we're loaded for Bowl
keep your eye on him though
[Applause]
he's unpredictable he's got that extra
stuff running through his body okay he's
in charge here he's very much in charge
because if I come in from the back maybe
I'll hold still a little bit
if I'm coming after him all bets are off
he could turn and charge me
Dan's doing a great job see Dan's got
him locked in
it's basically like a matador trying to
hold them in place for me
[Music]
it looked like a bullseye to me
I mean this is basically our only chance
to check this bowl out
to see why he's kind of dragging his
foot
you know if he's got that serious leg
injury he's not likely to feel up to
breeding oh there he goes he laid down
now we're going to go ahead and start
putting his leg through a range of
motion and really checking it out
why don't we rotate him onto this side
since we're gonna be checking out the
other foot
better
the boys are looking looking good though
no obvious injuries at all definitely no
fracture it's no sign of a like a nail
or a piece of metal in there
between his feet no no warts or anything
like that nothing
It's actually an amazingly pretty good
looking food
look in between his toes like between
the two claws I see very healthy skin no
sign of any lesions or scabs so we're
gonna go ahead and take some X-rays and
make sure we don't see fractures
arthritis anything like that that we
need to address
thank you
so you get worried when you're one bull
that you are banking on does not breed
the rest of the cattle we really like
this little bowl
hello friend
there we go
yeah those look really good I don't see
any sign of any
swelling there's no foreign body
so looking at the X-rays I see a very
normal hind foot I mean all the bones
going down into it the two claws of his
hoof are totally normal so we suspect
this is probably a slowly resolving
nerve injury
okay what I picture happening if he's
dragging that is almost like he's
splayed yes on the ice right and then
that's when they drag it
time to wake our boy up very common in
cattle when they're out running around
in the ice and snow is they will slay
one leg out and when they do that that
stretches the nerves that are basically
in the groin and then they can drag that
leg for quite a while and it will
resolve sometimes but it can take months
to do that you think he's in pain at all
no I don't really like he really was
moving pretty well that was my concern
if he was
hurt and 24 7. that's super good news
look out girls I think a number of them
are paying attention to what we're
saying
Buttercup
I would suspect he's been able to
breathe for a while now since it it is a
slow injury and he's probably been
getting better quite a bit over the last
couple months
oh buddy so the next test now is
basically to see if he actually did the
deed how about this one doc that looks
like a good one so now we're gonna go
have a look at the cows and see if
they're pregnant
okay she's right here might be able to
sneak a shot over a horse if one's
pregnant then it's likely he's got a lot
of pregnant cows here
Marlin Marlin leave for B they always
know when they're sedated
here she is if these girls turns up
pregnant then we're gold
if not we'll have to replace him with
another bull
so we're kind of worried about him he's
actually super important to us
can I have the ultrasound I just want to
be really sure so Johnny and I have made
a bet here he believes she's pregnant
I said there's no way there's no
possible way that she's pregnant I'm
thinking like was this leg injury bad
could he knock it around
um so we'll see okay
[Music]
a lot is writing on this preg check I
mean if she's not pregnant the bull is
going to be benched so it's important
that he's doing his job if he wants to
stay here in this little Slice of Heaven
he's got going on
[Music]
so she is definitely pregnant no way
yeah told you shut up give me a hundred
dollars
the Dank cow is pregnant totally lost a
bet but in all in all reality I'm so
excited about that that shows that we'll
be able to continue on this herd
apparently our boy here is doing his job
that's a game changer for us the best
news I've had probably this month to
find out that that guy was pregnant it
just made my day that leads me to
believe that he's impregnated the rest
of these gals
so we're very happy and we have no plans
on changing him out
ever since the dog showed up good things
has been happening right I mean he comes
over here and gives us the news that we
do have pregnant cows she looks at our
Bull and says he got another round left
in him maybe she'll find a buried
treasure chest before we get home I
don't know
sometimes the plan comes together huh
yep
five Butter Cup
[Music]
thank you
okay we need to go like right now
[Music]
this morning Dan came running in and
said this horrible tragedies happen
where Chester Kelly's son puppy down
underneath the tires the four-wheeler
while Kelly was driving and apparently
she rolled over him twice oh
no
when did it happen 10 minutes ago
oh this is such a nightmare
oh
foreign
as soon as we open the door into Kelly's
basement Chester does not look good he
is in complete shock his gums are
totally pale and white and he's scared
and the very first thing we're going to
do is pop an IV in and basically treat
him for shock make sure he's warm make
sure he's comfortable and getting lots
of fluids I'm very worried about Chester
oh baby
and his heart's racing a little bit
because he's in shock
we'll get the blood pressure mount
around him too
here we go buddy okay I was driving
really slow I turned the corner
and then you just hear the thud we
picked him up and Gracie came running
and all the things you learn as a farm
kid you just say hold him and love him
hold him close as you can because this
might be it just as long as he knows
that you love him till the very end
[Music]
juice
Chester is barely moving he's drooling
like crazy shocking of itself could be
dangerous because it's kind of causing a
Cascade of events I think he's got a
little abrasion yeah he's done right
there yeah see that the Tango in a
shotgun die from shock itself where your
your organs your brain your heart's just
not getting enough enough blood
this temperature is coming back up
that's really good
everything's stable now but we're going
to leave them on IV fluids it's amazing
how fluids can kind of keep them going
but now we've got to you know take a
deep breath and do a very calm and
collected assessment to see what the
extent of the trauma is
that sounds weird
lungs sound a little raspy
he's gurgling a little bit as he's
breathing it definitely sounds rough it
could mean damage to internal organs and
internal bleeding
so we're gonna get out the ultrasound to
figure this out
I want to look for any sign of abdominal
bleeding if he's bleeding internally we
need to basically jump the surgery
Somehow Here
Chester's Grayson's dog he'd wake up at
4 45 in the morning come work the dairy
to earn everything he needed to be able
to buy Chester and since that day it was
they've been inseparable
Grayson lost
Chester it would just
shatter him
I definitely don't see any extra fluid
in there so all that looks normal
I'm very relieved to see all the organs
kind of look to be in the normal spot
also I'm not seeing a lot of extra fluid
a little bit for sure there's a little
bit of bleeding in his belly but it's
not a lot and it's not increasing so
that's a really good sign
these little kick reflex checking as
reflexes there's a little slow
replaces it
typically
where his legs are underneath them as
I'm moving his feet there's definite
spinal cord trauma he's really not able
to use his hind legs properly at this
point
I'm really concerned about a broken back
or a broken pelvis so we're going to set
up for x-rays as well
I actually told him I said I don't
believe that there is any hope but we
will try
what did I tell you to do
pray
all right why don't we start getting
some x-rays then
[Music]
um
I'm trying to get some chest x-rays
first I want to make sure I don't see
any sign of the fractures of the ribs
great
but also getting rolled over by a wheel
can cause some bleeding in the lungs and
that can also make the graspy kind of
heavy lung sound
right where the x-rays if you want to
take a look
the diaphragm looks fine yeah amazingly
I don't see any fractures there let's
look further back
okay that looks pretty darn good too
yeah this purpose is looking fine oh
that's so lucky yeah
looking at the chest I don't see any
sign of lapsed lung there's no rib
fractures the lungs do look a little bit
cloudy so that's likely some bleeding
but nothing that's really scary and
that's something that can resolve on its
own over a few days and I think the best
news of all is we don't see any
fractures I don't know how he made it
underneath two big four-wheeler tires
without any fractures but everything
actually is lined up in where it should
be
sometimes I feel like when they're soft
and young and Squishy they just kind of
like roll through it somehow
knowing that Chester does have damage to
his spinal cord means something happened
and it can progress over time yeah so no
fractures and pelvis looks totally
normal so that's fantastic he's going to
be a sore puppy but we'll give him some
pain meds and you know it'll be a couple
weeks of keeping them quiet yeah there's
so much relief
enjoy I'm super happy oh my God I like I
am ecstatic
I mean oh what a chance do we have two
beds not only on the island but here
for me that's a God thing so
Kelly has turned to me a couple times
now and said you know thank God you were
here I just can't believe you guys are
here and I'm feeling the same way I'm
just so grateful we were here to help
what a Lucky Puppy
[Music]
okay ready
let's flip pigs
today is Piglet castration day we have
five to do today there are about 40-ish
pounds we're gonna sedate each one hi
we're also keeping an eye over on Alexa
and the pen next door she has been in
active laborer for quite a while like 24
hours but she still hasn't progressed to
be pushing out kids
our unicorn goat Alexa Alexa the goat we
kind of call her the Unicorn goat
because she has one horn she hasn't had
a baby before and it's always a little
bit tricky for a first time Mom and we
want to make sure that we're there and
she does kid we don't want her to have
problems
all right Maya you can help me I'll flip
it you need to stabilize it while I
inject it
here we go six week old piglets are like
naughty puppies they're silly whipping
around screaming at the slightest
movement so when you're trying to sedate
them they're a bit of a pain
they scream if you touch them if you try
and pet them if you try and move them a
certain way no matter what you are doing
to them
they only have one level which is Scream
[Music]
oh my gosh castrations are usually
pretty simple but I am so sensitive to
like loud noises
[Music]
and that pig squeal is like something
from another planet
okay ready
even though there was a bit of squealing
it's working
we're gonna double team it today and
just do them boom boom and try to get
all five of them done quickly
it's not heavy yeah this one's fat
[Music]
this is our little uh swine mesh set up
here mobile Armory swine Hospital yes
I think they're already looking sedate
incoming incoming pigs
beautiful Smiley thing
I love our Clinic setup out here in the
trees in the open air kind of prepared
for every eventuality
no the cat's back
except for a barn cat jumping onto our
surgical site out of nowhere no you
don't cookie the cat is one of the farm
cats here and I think she would be a
great Clinic cat but she is getting a
little bit nosy now
[Music]
okay good job penny is at least
you can check all right
usually castrations are very quick but
hopefully we don't see any that have
hernias and that makes castrations
really tricky
okie dokie Pig number one no little
piggy come on friend
there you go there we go
do you want me to take your testicles
you can take the pig's testicles yeah
I'm sorry awkward awkward conversations
between New Friends
okay who's next
okay
okay this one has a huge hernia
we're clipping through these castrations
and all of a sudden I see a ginormal
hernia
hernia means there's a hole in the
abdominal wall right in the region where
the testicle comes through that can be a
much more complicated procedure so
that's a hernia the intestines come out
right into that scrotum oh I can feel it
as I'm getting my fingers kind of
pressing in his groin area to feel the
hernia my heart kind of sinks so big
it's massive
feel that ring that kind of area that's
open the hernia ring is quite large so
that's going to be a bugger to close up
it can be tricky to prepare these
hernias in one risk you could cut open
the intestines accidentally this is
going to be a lot more serious than we
thought
because you're making the incision on my
fingers right okay right on that hernia
okay sure this is going to be tricky to
close that area that's open the hernia
ring and I'm thrilled that Dan and I are
doing this together because it's great
to suddenly have an extra set of hands
Dr Dan's gonna push the hernia back in
but we're gonna have to push the
intestines down into the abdominal wall
and hold them while we can kind of like
whip that big hernia ring closed and
it's actually a real struggle to kind of
get those two edges to meet and to get
those sutures tied because it's so down
deep in the groin
[Music]
what's happening
oh
and you go manage that I think we're
okay
towels are here all right let's go
[Music]
just give it a second she's in this
corner
it's just our lock when we're in the
middle of a very difficult hernia repair
that this is when Alexa decides to drop
her baby oh gosh
[Music]
we we can't leave either of these
animals so it we are extremely fortunate
today to have two teams
it's just stalled out Alexa has been in
and out of rethinking she's going to
have the baby drives me crazy she is
excited to stop she's up she's down she
pushing is this happening should I alert
everybody here we go and then nothing
happens she's almost got me to the point
that I don't believe that she's actually
pregnant
basically we're just sitting here
staring at a goat's backside until
something happens
I'm gonna go back and check
okay how the surgeries do okay let me
know if you need a hand over there
we go digging
so the hernia it's a very very large
hole Yeah
yeah a little bit of
tension on there whatever way you want
a little bit of surgical twister because
it's like my hands are in holding
a lot of like left hand on ring right
hand on suture you know left foot still
just trying to balance but it's great
that we can work together literally side
by side elbow tailboat getting the ring
closed
stop
it's just getting louder and louder
Maya struggles with
hearing the animals cry or hearing that
upset
come on now
and even though I reassure her that it's
it's not feeling it we've got it totally
blocked she's very
affected by that which is an awesome
part of Maya deep into the muscle not
into my finger right there right there
right at it he's been difficult to keep
down at anesthesia so we've just given
him a bunch of top-ups and we're giving
that a little bit of time to take effect
okay I'm gonna go tell Sierra that
there's like an emergency or something
so that she runs down here and doesn't
notice that I hang back and then she
gets stuck with this job
[Music]
thank you for your help
she doesn't want to keep holding on to
them and I think it's a little bit more
fun to go see the baby being born
goats are kind of no drama they kind of
just don't care but pigs on the other
hand are like a
bucket of drama they said they didn't
need someone to hold the hold the pig
down
I knew she was lying like I'm okay well
if you want to switch out you could just
say you gotta switch out because I could
tell when you're lying do you work with
your kids ever
help you out in the field sometimes
here hold right here for just right now
completely close here
[Music]
as soon as I got in there I thought I
was going to be able to chill out and
relax with the goats
I was escaping
and she started kidding so then Kelly
kind of got in to try and start helping
hi mom
um
I'm worried that the piece of the sack
broke
your baby out okay I'm gonna grab her
yep
I reach in I feel her water breaks
normally that water breaks as the baby
gushes out with the water that has not
happened okay oh my goodness
as soon as that sack pops
I don't have oxygen anymore we have a
short window of time to get that baby
out this is go time to save this baby's
life oh my goodness holy I don't know if
it was with that but that's what I want
you to feel
a burst of water came out right out to
me
the sack did just break
[Applause]
oh
Alexa is really struggling this is an
emergency when you have a ruptured
amniotic sack and the baby is actually
still in the vaginal Canal like it's no
longer getting oxygen from the mom you
got to get that baby out within minutes
[Music]
I don't want to lose a goat to lose the
life's gonna be horrible
um and a big
[Applause]
blows
it's like the telescope I get it
take a breath
oh there you go
hey
Alexa has a big-headed boy baby so cute
he's one of the biggest kids that I've
seen and that really explains it to have
such a big kid coming out of a
first-time mom is a pretty big stretch
okay you guys got this part
that you did that way to go lady it
makes me nervous anytime a vet comes
rushing into your PIN
I'm not really a trained professional so
I'm really thankful to have one that was
a tough one she was really struggling
actually so now that I've got the kid
out I'm getting back to the piglet
surgery because Dan and I need to finish
this hernia yeah there it is
do I have the hernia retained I can't
see I can see it here
[Music]
it's a baby
almost before we can fully wrap our
brains around this we have another baby
like gliding through and it's fully in
its sack which is amazing
oh it's tiny tiny it just flew out oh
you look good I think that that guy was
blocking everything up yeah he's big
most likely this kid was kind of ready
to come out but big brother was blocking
the door so I'm just rubbing her and
she's starting to come around great
we're making something happen over here
so good I'm gonna go back to the pigs
okay
we definitely closed up part of it oh
it's closed nice work boom right nice
each time I've had to go and come back
I'm very happy to see that Dan is making
progress so it's really nice to have
another vet that's still there finishing
the procedure
done friend we're almost done
it's tough to deal with multiple things
happening at once when you're out at a
farm but you know you can't schedule in
birth you know it's gonna happen whether
you're ready or not because we were
already in one surgery you just have to
multitask and roll with it get out get
out get out get out oh jeez Piggies up
running around he looks great the
incision is all closed up and we
actually got both babies and Alexa so it
was a very successful day we did it we
did it we made it every single new life
is special unique and absolutely the
best you think you'd get used to it you
never do and I'm so thankful for it I
think probably the day that you think
it's normal you should quit because it's
fantastic
[Music]
hi Penny
so now that we've got goats kitted and
piglets castrated we're gonna go check
on on Chester it's been a week since he
was hit by the four-wheeler and he
couldn't quite use his back end so
hopefully he's showing some improvement
now
hello hello
what oh
are you kidding me Chester come here how
much for keeping him quiet anymore I
know it's really hard he looks
incredible what
oh boy
Chester is doing fantastic Chester is
running Chester is playing Chester is
jumping
it's unbelievable look at him wagging
his little tail looking at Chester now
I'm kind of Blown Away
everything we've done to help him this
work so
kind of live for these days okay let's
see what you're doing with the back end
here okay good boy Siri oh now you know
how to do it isn't that nuts no problem
you're passing every test I'm throwing
at you every test oh you're doing so
good oh my good checkup I'm like I hope
he's not dragging his hand I know it's
amazing
I can't believe a week ago we were
sitting here thinking that Chester would
no longer be part of our family let's
grow something
you know you often hear that cats have
nine lives Farm dogs don't get that same
chance usually
there's only a few times you know where
I feel like oh I absolutely just saved
that animal's life
but being right here right now that just
feels like we were here because we
needed to be here and I love that I love
that we were aware we needed to be at
the right place at the right time where
I could help
living in this place with
[Music]
living in this home we've made